okie dokie welcome to this video playing
i am w salad that's probably the name
Ian voila salvaged from Egypt okay so
let's see a sloth maybe the main line ok
go's g6 that's very uncommon line going
for somewhat somewhat second-rate
versions of the exchange sloth yeah
quickly played but not quite sure this
is so great for black to go to again
King go to before or other other ideas
but my queen is actively placed here
putting some pressure on him the problem
of this setup for black is some that he
has this some yeses problem with b7 porn
and one long term problem is the bishop
on g7 is really a bad piece it just
looks at this well protected d4 pawn and
yeah it's um it's not easy to play okay
what about this if I cheeky for cheeks
Bishop c7 looks like and winning the
winning the night he's attacking my
night though so it's not totally simple
affair I still it looks looks good right
let's put this on where is his Queen
going in the first place
in many cases I even have Bishop to b5
ended at least wins the pawn of calcium
like EF GF if I return the night only
form
on the other hand if I take on a 5 with
the bishop I'm trapping it like a sixer
it's a self trap okay so he's
voluntarily going into rooks e5 isn't
this a bit weird okay rook c5 Queen d7
arm
I have Bishop b5 then 96 queen bee some
but that looks really awkward
let's do this mmm yeah I can take be
some night or not let's take b7 wow how
weird where's he putting the Queen now I
see planning to play some wacky Queen
sacrifice like II takes a three or
something I cannot really believe it
works now he just has the Queen anthem
and the night here
don't see a move him at least that
should be up like two pawns in most
cases 27 like Quincy 6 for example he
takes a three take these seven taken
three it's two pawns and and a winning
position
probably has to go 27 I mean not that
this is particularly attractive but what
else is there Queen e6 I can play rook
c67 just pees up
yeah I think he had to do that yeah this
is just a keep it simple method I'm two
pawns up and have a good control iam so
looks looks really fine not getting into
any pinning travels black resigned yeah
it's okay it's not early but it's a bit
early for blitz but it's really kind of
hopeless I can easily just push push the
pants nothing nothing you can do
somewhere I cannot draw I don't know
yeah I can just push push the pause here
yeah the thing is that this line with G
success is already a bit iffy the bishop
on g7 is simply not well placed it
doesn't help to play on the on the
queenside this bishop and wide we'll
have some nice play on the C file with
with easy with really easy moves just
like I'm I played it it's always a bit
better for white yeah on the queenside I
mean my pieces all relate to the
queenside yeah the bishop is looking
into the position night can come here
night here it has idea so I have lots of
pressure there and this Bishop one g7 is
not it's just sitting there it's doing
nothing in defense and the same applies
with some lesser degree to those pieces
k went here rook see one looks normal
here yeah and now it's a matter of
choice here I mean this is definitely
not bad but this simple move is also
quite good he has to take and I'm
definitely in good shape now I mean this
is this is a terrible position with this
idea
but this is concrete and and good I
think went here yeah of course I can
still take on a five with the queen but
rook c5 looked very tempting yeah this
is losing straight away I think Queen d7
as much he has to do I was thinking I'm
that Bishop b5 is interesting with now
and here and here actually made a
complete miscalculation I was thinking I
can take on be 70 which is kind of
illegal yeah okay something like this is
still probably quite good yeah that's
proof thats quite good actually that's
nice wide as a bit better here but not
that not that's not the best so I should
have taken on a 500 taking taken them
the pawn yeah maybe pawn takes you to be
quicker here yeah that was better but he
went here and after that is just dead
lost yeah that's it that's a lost end
game 2 points 2 cons is too much yeah
that's something that you can maybe use
yourself if you play the Slav with white
here the move g6 is really am this is
close to being a mistake due to the
captcha on d5 it's some simply nodded
not a good setup okay well thanks for
watching